okay welcome to the second session on
complexity Theory so we'll begin with
the talk by Ericson on essentially
Optimus interactive certificates
engineering
thank you caitan thank you for the
invitation to
speak here
this talk as I told caitan has a
geometry in it but no complexity Theory
and then he said well if the algorithms
are optimal it's complexity Theory so uh
they're only essentially optimal I wrote
down here on the Whiteboard
that I allow myself
optimality within a factor that is
input size to the little o of one so
this notation of having an exponent a
little of one I will use a lot
and you have to think of it of having
this factor in front of the complexity
that this may be a polylog I learned
this notation from folkestrasen I
remember when he showed it to me
the dinner at the conference
the little oval you can you can kill two
constants not just one
to be all constant and then also the
exponent in the log so
and uh in distinction do I think
most of what was
spoken here about
my complexity is bit complexity so
uh
we heard about the matrix multiplication
exponent and then
people say that
this matrix multiplication exponent is
in is in all of linear algebra problems
but it's not true you will see uh so uh
this was actually not the motivating
example but it is an example that
brought in my co-author I didn't mention
my course
this is how he came on board
he he is a person who builds a
uh linear algebra it builds a linear
algebra Library for for exact linear
algebra computation it's called linbox
and uh because we are on the web we get
these matrices sent to us from
this one was sent from a from K
theorists and this is a matrix 2 million
by 2 million and they wanted to know the
rank and uh so so we could have cheated
we could have looked up the papers and
seen what conjecture they made they just
returned the value of that contexture
but we didn't we computed the rank in a
thousand CPU days then we gave them the
rank and they were happy was that what
they conjectured uh I don't know so so
so it's with a with a Monte Carlo
algorithm or we do not know in Las Vegas
algorithm for computing the rank of a
sparse Matrix over a finite field this
is not known to us
and the question is do you believe the
rank so
so what what this talk is about this
that I don't just give you the rank I
give you a certificate
and you can quickly quickly in
essentially linear time in your input
size
verify that the rank is uh is the rank
so the the number returned is is the
rank of the Matrix so the motivation
actually came from
uh sums of squares
where we construct It ultimately
integer matrices large integer matrices
I'll show it briefly how how the how how
you can get a proof for a polynomial
inequality
by by two uh
integer matrices and then the proof is
to to prove that these two integer
matrices a positive semi-definite
and uh
that that was the problem in which I
formulated this notion of a certificate
I require
I I at that time we were we didn't I had
a sort of Appliance but I didn't look at
interactive certificates there is a a
soundness and a completeness
and something the soundness is that the
certificate cannot lie to you
and uh
the the completeness is that for every
input you you produce that you can
produce such a certificate
the Assumption of course that we make
today uh didn't make it then I only said
it it had to be of of a lesser
computation asymptotic computational
complexity the verification procedure
then it took to compute the the output
and the certificate so uh
the day we we are after linear
essentially linear time certificate so
this is a bit complexity that is
proportional to the number of bits in
the input
linear time
now uh the way you write it up in the in
The Proposal is that this is of course
cloud computing the cloud we get the use
of a of a Google data center for a
weekend and
the data center computes something and
then we are able on our workstation in
our lab to verify that what the Google
get the data center produced is is the
correct answer I
I did for this uh
forensic because I I'm sometimes asked
by complexity theories isn't that the
man oil blooms
programs that check their answers it is
not the certificate has to be verifiable
in a lesser complexity then you need for
computing the output
they allow to rerun the program to check
the output so they have a rank
certificate but it would not be linear
time because they have to have to rerun
the the rank program on a modified
Matrix that's what they do but it is it
is what I learned actually later after
after we we started this certificate it
is what uh uh South Africa gold was a
collioned called the Muggles proof so
this is an ocean where you do an
Interactive
uh proof that the computation was
performed and you limit the proof in
complexity and I I'll come back to this
I show you exactly what they did so
let's get started here quickly uh my
talk
uh
uh kitten
you should understand everything not
like what we discussed at lunch so so
the the spa certificates are not based
on this but all our
the certificates for dense learning
algebra based on this this is losing
freiber it's a certificate certificate
that the uh quadratic time certificate
from for the matrix product and this is
a Monte Carlo certificate yeah what is
the certificate the certificate is the
product there's no additional data
structure with it
and how does the the verify how does
Victor
check that that Matrix C is the product
of A and B uh C multiplies uh the
product from the right with a with a
random vector
and uh
he also multiplies he he is Victor he is
the verifier so so he also multiplies
the the C Matrix from the right with the
with the random vector and if the two
vectors agree then with high probability
it's the problem
and actually
uh the the the
freibel's paper has another certificate
to verify that the product of two
integers is a third integer which is
also of better complexity than integer
multiplication so
there has been a little bit of progress
on the certificate you can you can limit
the number of random bits you need
uh the the trick here is to to choose
your your vector y uh
a random Vector of of consecutive powers
and then have even written down the
proof here because then if if you have
enough such vectors distinct vectors uh
not half of them can lie to you because
otherwise you would have uh
the difference times a phantom on Matrix
to be zero in that that so uh with that
uh uh we we immediately get uh it's a
difficult for non-singolarity so
uh this is again a point to the
Whiteboard we are talking about the
uh
bit complexity here so the so the Matrix
is here integer matrices
and uh so there's a difficult
that Peggy returns is a smallish small I
give this talk as a rehearsal in in
China and they told me I should explain
what I mean by smallish Prime so so this
Prime is of a size so that you have a
that they have a probability of success
bounded away from zero
and that you preserve the essential
linearity so there is a trade-off if the
prime is too large then you're no longer
essentially linear and if the prime is
too small you don't have a non bounded
away from zero probability of of success
that that the output is verified and
it's just the Lup factorization you say
you can
you can buy Fireballs you can check
whether this is the Lup factorization
model of p and then the the alanine and
and the U will actually tell you that
the Matrix is nothing
regularity certificate is a little bit
more interesting so here we just expose
a column relation a trouble being that
the column relation on an integer Matrix
can have n Bits so these so the column
relation can have can can have a number
of bits that that is proportional to the
dimension of the Matrix so you have
actually N squared bits in the column
relation
and so you cannot perform the product
you cannot say eight times the column
relation because this would cause you
cubic bit time so what you again do is
you you choose a smallish Prime you take
the column relation mold or load that
smallish Prime
and then check whether it's a it's a
it's a column relation
a modular p and uh since uh since Victor
chooses chooses that smallish Prime
randomly with high probability this is a
column relation
uh for that integer Matrix so so so this
is these are the immediate cases
interestingly enough they're not in 5
volts paper
uh I I checked it out I thought this
would be in five months paper already so
so the first difficult one is rank so
you have an integer Matrix
and you want to
to certify the rank with an additional
piece of data in the output
and the first certificate we came up
with in 2011
uh also use this Luv factorization
but now of course
the
uh the P the p is given by by Peggy and
uh so Peggy can cheat You by choosing a
p where the Matrix drops in rank and you
can prevent this by forcing Peggy to
give you many many such Luv
factorizations modulo different primes
now to prove that the
you have a a Monte Carlo
success with with checking these Lup
factors and if they see you you need a
linear number of primes so this is a
certificate that is cubic space and it's
not going to to be a quadratic
uh essentially optimal certificate but
it's kind of funny because it has a lot
of space but you actually can randomly
sample from that certificate Victor can
randomly sample a few such Lup
factorizations and he would get a
certainty that with high probability
that this is the rank but
so someone hands here Matrix with
integer entries and you want to know the
rank yeah and then someone performs this
luk factorization and from that you read
off the rank and now you want to know if
it's correct
and is it that point you reduce mod P
that's where um yeah so so this is a
great great remark because you see so
you see no it's a good question because
because the value B factorization
actually
the exact Lup factorization occupies
cubic space
it's n cubed but I'm basically very
naive question when do you reduce smart
page reduce this month
I approve
factorization the proverb reduces smart
P Google has to give you the matrices
modulo P because the approval Returns
the approver returns all this
okay
you see the proof I also could do an
irrational lub factorization
computer science that's not that's that
far worse than that
yeah
so I guess you're supposed to trust her
for Peggy kitchen no no no no no you
don't have to trust her because she gave
you so many Luv factorizations that she
can only cheat you on a linear number of
them so if you sample five times you're
going to hit a good one
so you're testing here using Chinese
there's no Chinese remaindering here
I mean you have to how do you check that
she's not cheating
the proof of course that that you
separate yourself from zero is by
Chinese
you have only a finite number of bad
Primes
the the drop the rank so that's the
proof yes absolutely
okay that comes later
okay yeah I I have have a screenshot
there so so actually
the funny thing is I I posed this
question to my colleagues and the
symbolic computation Community to reduce
this to to to to quadratic space
and uh for for two years didn't get an
answer and I immediately oh I didn't
know that I had this in between yeah so
so
this is
a
a summary of
complexity for linear algebra objects
other than the matrix product
so the rank
actually
to compute the rank of a matrix
it's it's of course uh
this is a Monte Carlo algorithm you
choose a smallish Prime so so you have
you have this n and I use Omega for the
matrix multiplication exponent not the
infimum here so so you have this matrix
multiplication complexity but
log of the bit length of the Matrix and
then you have another
quadratic term this is this is a term
this is the number of bits you have in
The Matrix so ladies and Gentlemen
please remember
if an integer Matrix
has long integers as entries
you can compute the rank in linear time
of the input size of the number of bits
in the input there is no
yeah essentially yeah every every time I
say linear I mean essentially linear yes
positive
there's also no no I don't want to say
quasi-linear I want to say essentially
this is Dan Bernstein's essentially now
so uh
but the rank is small
and the rank is small
you you can do it in
quadratic time no matter what
essentially linear
well this is the number of pits you have
in the input
the log of the norm of a that's simply
the length
of the the number of bits in The Matrix
no no no no that's dense matrices that's
dense matrices and uh this the to prove
that you can compute the rank of a
matrix
that there has this lower rank in in in
optimal time that that takes a little
bit of work that is not entirely obvious
because you can't do Lu factorization it
would be non-linear
saying in this formula if the normal a
is sufficiently large then this the term
with the unknown exponent of Omega is
will be less then yeah so so so yeah if
you have npt integers
if you have an N band Matrix with an NPD
integers you do it in N Cube time
now there is
there is there are famous results for us
in the symbolic computation Community
for computing the determinant and the
rank
in and do the Omega times the length of
the input so so so why is this why is
this uh famous yeah because if you use
Chinese remaindering you get an extra
factor of n
and it takes a lot of work to get rid of
this extra fact of it and store your
hands paper
there's 54 Pages it's it's the most
complicated determinant algorithm I know
all right uh and he later also did it
for rank the game
yeah yeah the bro yeah it's in Las Vegas
it's so so for for rank also because
multi-color would already be better
right so the answer is always correct
right
when it's Monte Carlo the answer Las
Vegas the answer is always correct and
you can just do it into the like into
the Omega times the bit length of the
input yeah so
now this I really don't know
that of course it's easy to explain what
what is Las Vegas I I know what Monte
Carlo is let's say so so Las Vegas it's
always correct but probably fast
so this the the the the the the running
time
is expected it could run longer uh but
the answer will always be correct so any
Monte Carlo algorithm where you can
check the answer is it Las Vegas all
good because you can run it again until
you get the right answer
all right
it's rainco
at you get a certificate
for the
uh for the rank
you see you simply run his algorithm
so the approver runs his his algorithm
and when when the matrix multiplication
is performed on Integer matrices
uh
they the product is stored
that's the certificate and then the
verifier reruns the algorithm re-run
store your hands algorithm but uh
when the algorithm has to perform a
matrix multiplication
they use 5 volts he uses five volt
certificate to check whether this matrix
product was performed right
so this is an essentially optimal
certificate for dance Matrix I think
it's it's still
the
it was performed is Monte Carlo so you
choose a random vector and with high
probability
you detect you detect a false product
so this is you will see this this is
actually quite similar to goldwasser
kalai and the
and the world Bloom they do something
very similar on arbitrary circuits
uh so
so what's the bad news this is great
news I discovered this uh two days
before the paper was due and I put it in
in the last section as as an essentially
optimal rank certificate for integer
matrices
so that's that's the good news the
determinant if we don't do this where we
do it in a much simpler way but uh
the bad news is
the Omega this matrix multiplication
exponent
cannot be achieved for all problems in
linear algebra we don't know how to do
this we do not know how to compute the
characteristic polynomial
in uh end of the Omega times bit size of
the inputs
yeah yeah so one two three four five six
and seven means so so so these are
parameters in this baby steps chain
steps algorithm and and the ETA
is the exponent that is achieved for
example for the characteristic
polynomial
and the characteristic polynomial has an
exponent of 2.69
okay
in-bit complexity
and what's interesting also I put this
down for the complexity Theory people
this is also the best known division
free complexity for the determinant the
determinant is a polynomial you should
be able to compute it on an arithmetic
circuit without the division
and the best known circuit is is larger
then the circuit for matrix
multiplication why is it not that it
just makes this power
this algorithm always needs to do is
making smaller and raising a matrix
so the big complexity
increases yeah this is exactly what it
is yeah our baby steps
it has n Cube that's
there's n cubed bits in the entrance
we have insequent entries and inches and
bits
and actually I mean we do exactly that
we only go to to a baby step we only go
to Escrow route of Empower and then we
do a giant step and puzzle it together
that's exactly what we do
all right so
so the upshot is
how do you get into into the Omega I
mean you need in Matrix multiplications
yeah yeah so this is this is uh
characteristic polynomial algorithm
well they I only want you to look at one
number this one uh so so
because this is the exponent that is
achieved by by these parameter settings
Joseph said what are what do these
parameters I so so mean there is of
course there is another exponent here
this is the exponent for rectangular
matrix multiplication so uh so you
multiply
uh and and N by n matrix by an N by end
of The
0.30 Matrix and you do it in quadratic
time and that's actually legal's
exponent they used to don't call basmic
exponent here so if you don't use fast
rectangular Matrix operations you get
you get a a small a slightly higher
exponent but uh uh I just put this down
because we don't know
how to compute the dismissed normal form
of a matrix in that time in the end of
the Omega this is all in bit complexity
we are not adding to the Omega
all right so it has a consequent
uh what what happened here
it has a consequence for for the
certificate I just showed you because
even if I had a quadratic
time algorithm for matrix product
the certificate would be n to the 2.5
because I would I would rather algorithm
but algorithm for Omega equal 2 doesn't
have exponent 2.
so I have a sub I have a super linear
certificate all right we will be after
the characteristic polynomial here so
that's what we want to do I I should say
that I I I realized this that uh
that somehow
in the certificate where we had these
many Lu B factorizations mod Primes
you could force the prover
to choose the Prime in a in a pre agreed
way
so that the approver cannot cheat you
so but I but for example you could you
could have a random primes generator
that uses it as as its seed a value that
depends on the Matrix
and of course this is a a notion known
from cryptography this would be a public
random function
you agree on a public random function
and then you also get
okay it essentially linear certificate
for ring right so this is modulo a
public random function because then you
only have to to inspect one Lu B
factorization mark p because P Peak
Peggy cannot manipulate p
all right uh but uh this doesn't help us
here
so
I
I have a another
uh 20 minutes so I will go over this
rather quickly it's actually funny that
this is the next workshop on Samsung
squares and semi-definite programming
why have you interested in the
characteristic polynomial to start with
so this is uh uh What uh
we want to do is we want to prove an
inequality a polynomial inequality that
that is valid uh for any real value of
the variables and this is just a note
this is for Global optimization so the
the global minimum is supposed to
satisfy such an inequality and you do it
why are sums of squares which essential
which which will lead you to positive
semi-definite matrices so I I called
polynomials positive semi-definitive if
they're
non-negative if they never attain a
negative value I I actually liked email
atten's paper very much because uh he he
in his paper
he writes for a definite
form for a definite form he writes a f
is not less than zero
and this is just great because it
doesn't write greater equals zero he had
not less than zero because it's it's
irrational faction so you can also hit
the a root of the denominator I leave
this here because this is this is a
symbol that's not so easy to type set in
that ticket well not less than that okay
all right so so what we want to do is
we want to use positive
semi-definiteness of symmetric matrices
this means that the Matrix
symmetric Matrix is real like values a
positive semi-definite Matrix has no
negative
eigenvalue and uh I have one screenshot
oh I'm sorry
uh and this of course can be tested from
the characteristic polynomial
characteristic polynomial if you have a
polynomial that has has has all real
Roots You can count the number of
positive roots and the number of
negative Roots by the by the car rule of
sine
here is the cheap version of the the
Carol of sign if you want to know
whether polynomial only has positive
Roots You evaluated at minus X and you
have to get positive coefficients
and this is an ethanol lift this is this
is this is the the the math 101 version
of the car rule of sign so so so from
the characteristic polynomial of this
positive semi-definite Matrix we will
we we will be able to prove that Matrix
that that Matrix is positive
semi-definite
that's why we want to have a certificate
for the characteristic polynomial so it
comes from
from this uh uh
fraction of sums of squares so you can
uh
take a fraction of sums of squares
and write it
it's a is it by linear form where where
the vectors are vectors of terms so and
the reason why this is an if and only if
it's because uh positive semi-definite
Matrix has a jolesque factorization so
you can go from from this Matrix
identity you can go back to the sums of
squares and what we what we do in our
algorithms we we compute these positive
semi-definite matrices
via
semi-definite programming plus a lot of
other stuff because it has to be an
exact identity
this cannot be a numeric identity
but once you have an exact identity and
if this Matrix is you have to you have
to you test them whether they are
positive semi-definite and they're
positive semi-definite you have a proof
so you can see this this inequality is
true
and the certificate is of course it's a
d you give the Matrix
you give these two positive summative
and then a proof
that uh uh for the characteristic
polynomial
and I want to do this in essentially
linear time
so that was the motivating example
this is how I started thinking about
this
because my collaboratory hangxi she said
oh you this is once you have the SOS you
just uh Square the polynomials and add
them up and that's the proof and then we
did some we did the polynomials for the
monotone column permanent conjecture and
so these these polynomials occupy 10
gigabytes of space and okay here's a
proof for your case of the mCP not
nothing nothing it was ramps ramps
problem check this 10 gigabytes with and
this is completely unnecessary because
all we had to do is give a proof
for the characteristic polynomial of the
matrices we constructed
color that was the motivation there's
there's a Samsung squares example
uh
all right
it's the goal and also sparse Matrix
rank I I will show you another
protocol for sparse Matrix and and
unfortunately
I have to admit
I have no Monte Carlo certificate I only
have a Monte Carlo certificate
when when you when there is a public
random function
so uh
the use of the public random function is
explained in
the the the the removal of interactivity
of uh of of the proof of knowledge
protocol I'm looking at the time so
so here I'm not entirely sure what the
setting is with proof of knowledge so so
let me just say this so so so you have
you've given you've given the proof a v
and to prove it claims
that she has computed the discrete
logarithm of that V
and you want you ask her to prove that
to you
so what uh what the prover does is
they give you an H with which is another
power of your of your primitive root
base
and so so so so so she commits that age
to you
and then
Victor to verifier sends a random
uh
a random order
and then the prover will will give to
the verifier the linear combination of
of the discrete log and that random
value that she has also chosen
with with a multiplier that is that c
and then the verifier can just check
whether this identity is right in the
exponent and the reason the reason why
the verifier doesn't gain access to
access
uh because discrete log is difficult
and this could be anything
so
that the very fire does not know R does
not know so so so so this is we put this
in it's kind of completely disconnected
from the dark but
you know it's uh you know like from this
where you know for example X model 2.
yeah it is it is uh in the same
a year that your knowledge was first
published yeah so yeah you're right
you're right there is additional
information so so so but but
interactive certificates but we're
actually not interested in this protocol
at all we're interested in how do you
remove the interactivity
and the interactivity is removed uh by
what I already had said before
you use
this random public function
so so the proven now
also produces like like I did with rank
produces that uh that that that
coefficient
that was used in the linear form by
hashing
on the values of the commitment
so so so so this this this random
function
prevents the proof from cheating
because there's commitment
and and this is what we want to use so I
have it here for rank so so this would
be the interactive protocol for rank
if one round brought the collabor I want
a half a round protocol right I don't
want I don't want interactivity at all
because uh once the Google data center
has has has computed the this rank they
say goodbye I don't want to to have
another question from you
and they're supposed to present the
certificate so
so you remove the interactivity simply
by hashing and this is what I said you
hash the random smallish Prime you
choose you hash from what the input is
with the random function are there any
questions
yes
in some sense
I mean is this you know probably because
it depends on the strength like the
strength it depends on the fact that you
have a public random function which is
assume without it it's not true actually
there's a proof
there's a proof purely random function
honestly well a random function in in
the in the notion of cryptography right
undistinguishable
the function is indistinguishable from a
random function
this this function here this hash
function you cannot distinguish it from
it can be truly random faction in in
polynomial time
in the sense of of cryptography
all right so so now I can give you my
certificate for the characteristic
polynomial uh
one wonders why this took me well it's
actually shankarian contributed to this
because he realized that we should do
interactive protocols so you commit the
characteristic polynomial and then the
verifier
sends a smallish Prime and then and the
random value back to the prover and the
proverb performs the the
certificate
for for the for the for the
characteristic polynomial evaluated at
that random value you see this is this
is a certificate for determinant now not
for characteristic polynomial
and I've written down the certificate
the certificate is an Lup factorization
model of that smallish Prime that the
that the verifier has provided and the
verified then just checks this Lu B
factorization with 5 volts algorithm and
and it also has to check the
characteristic polynomial that was
committed evaluates
do that determinant that was sent back
uh
if I don't have much time
one has to think about it why this is
why this is a sound why why the approver
cannot cheat you
and of course the
part is the difference wrong
characteristic polynomial is sent
then
you just the the the prover just just
cannot
cannot fake this determinant because
this is a certificate for the
determinant
so there will be a disagreement in the
evaluation of the characteristic
polynomial and the determinant the
deserted
and of course you can
take out
the interactivity by by field Jamia
by just hashing the the smallish Prime
and that random value at which we
evaluate
from from both now from both the input
Matrix and the characteristic polynomial
this is important the commitment of the
characteristic polynomial
because otherwise the proof of just
adjusts the characteristic polynomial so
that there is agreement that are with
the determinant
so this would be
what what what what what you see here
would be
a certificate for the SOS proof
that's how you do an SOS proof
you have this Matrix and you get this
and you check it then you know this
polynomial inequality with high
probability is true
verification complexity is essentially
linear
the input size
and again the the quadratic time comes
in both evaluating this characteristic
polynomial at this
a smallish random value and
checking the Lup factorization with five
it looks so simple afterwards why why
did it take me three years
so
this would be
an interactive protocol for
for his past Matrix rank
uh so
so it it's very similar except
you cannot no longer do the Lup
factorization
because the Matrix is sparse in the Lup
factorization can become dense so you
use a brick conditioner
so this this triplets Matrix is a
preconditioners that that put
the product Matrix into generic rank as
we say where all the leading principles
of matrices up to rank and non-singular
and then what we do is we we certify
uh that uh
that the R by R leading principles of
Matrix is non-singular and we do we
cannot we cannot do this with an Lu pre
factorization so you do this with a
random right side vector and you force
the proof to to give you a solution for
the system it's a small H Prime it's not
a small Prime so so there's not so so
you can control here the probability
that this is right and then you also
need
a certificate that the r plus one by R
plus one leading principle sub Matrix is
singular and and you do this with the
columnization
so this would have been this is for for
integer matrices so actually
this would have been the certificate for
this big Matrix
that uh
that I showed you at the very beginning
I have five minutes left yeah here
it's uh if the Matrix has a has a linear
number of non-zero entries you get uh
linear time
I should say this maybe at this point
for sparse matrices for matrices
that have uh
n to the one plus little of one non-zero
entries
the best algorithm we know
to compute the rank and the best
algorithm we know to compute the
determinant is quadratic in n
this is worse
than for dance matrices dance matrices
for dance matrices even the cubic
algorithm isn't really cubic
because they're N squared entries
what's even worse for these sparse
matrices that we do not have even a
quadratic algorithm for computing the
characteristic polynomial
the best algorithm is n to the 2.5
this is a super quadratic
polynomial time algorithm
and I always ask people happy
what's the most famous polynomial time
algorithm where the best algorithm is
cubic in the input size I don't know
there should be one right
at least cubic yeah it's not so he is
okay okay
all right
deterministic family did this
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah
all right I want to say a little bit
about uh because I have four minutes
left about this uh this uh
uh uh PCP based
uh
proofs of the computation so we we this
paper was was brought to my attention
actually
I went to Shafi gold versus Target Duke
University where she gives a touring
talk and she had this in one of her
screens and so I asked her afterwards so
uh if you have a
an NC family of circuits you can
you can provide the verifier with the an
interactive protocol
that certifies that the
circuit was evaluated
faithfully and the verifier complexity
is very small it's essentially linear in
the input size
uh uh The Proven complexity
is is of course the issue we want to
stay with essentially linear and verify
a complexity and then we want to bring
the prover complexity down
and uh so
there was only polynomial
in the complexity of the circuit itself
and this was improved for certain
circuits that there's a restriction on
the circuit
to Big O
in the size of the circuits and what's
interesting about our construction is
all our certificates
can be can be provided
uh with an additional little all of
complexity
it took to compute the output so so we
don't even double the cost on the prover
side
now this is important to us you see if
you have a gigantic sparse Matrix and
and and somebody comes to you and says
I can certify your your rank
but it will take you 10 times as much
you might be dead because the
computation already takes a month
so
so this is uh What uh what the result is
and
I I have to admit to you
that I don't entirely understand the
proof I looked at it
it is based even even there's a protocol
in it that that I don't quite understand
the difficulty is not to to to verify
each level of the circuit but how you
make sure that when you switch to the
next level you there's no cheating done
so
but what what is what is important here
is that and
uh this is this is of course true uh
this is an interactive protocol say for
the problem we we looked at at the
beginning which was the rank of an
integer Matrix
an interactive protocol but you can
remove
I don't know how many rounds it is then
look at this actually Tyler constructs
uh multi-round
uh protocols for the matrix product
don't know how many rounds it has but
you could it's you should be able to
remove
the interactivity by via champion
this is an alternate to what we were
doing
oh this is my
last
um I'm out of time but there is a there
is one aspect of this of this
interactive protocol
we don't quite like
which is
so if there is if if the circuit if this
if if you have a program to compute a
determinant that has a bug in it
you will not uncover the bag with your
certificate
because the certificate will just be a
certificate for the fact that you
carried out the computation
so what we actually like in our
certificate as a difficult where the
verification is independent
of how the output has been computed
all right uh
what's the consequence for algebraic
geometry
in algebraic geometry
all computations are exponential in the
number of variables
is it true I guess so right it's true
right I don't know what it means by that
I wouldn't sign this you wouldn't you
wouldn't say this true
you would
exponential in the number of variables
at least
so I cannot ask
like the number of solutions yeah yeah
but you see with this
you may be able it's not quite true
because it's also the the number of him
with this you may be able to certify
them polynomial time
you may be able to certify computational
I think this is important because the
computations are so complex
so if you ran half a year the
certificate is then quick
this is not not so bad
often used in practice but please don't
play I don't know if this year so so so
this here is the problem right
you cannot afford
to to substantially increase the time
of the computation to also get the
certificate the certificate has to come
out
with very little extra effort
um
and out of time I'm over time
we have no
certificate I showed you a certificate
for sparse rank
but the rank of response Matrix we have
no certificate for the determinant of
his pass Matrix
don't know how to certify
such a quantity in linear time in the
input
know how to do it uh
but what what also would be nice is if
we would have a certificate for the
characteristic polynomial
that that doesn't depend on this
cryptographic assumption you see our
rank doesn't depend on the cryptographic
assumption
but the the determinant doesn't depend
on the cryptographic assumption but but
the characteristic polynomial does
and uh I shall conclude I that's how I
try to sell this this work so so so
there is an entire area that this uh uh
computer algebra and cryptography where
grubner is applied to Breaking crypto
schemes so so that field applies
symbolic computation to cryptography
and with our certificates we have gone
the other way we have a blight
cryptography
to symbolic computation
thank you very much you
but maybe the third of the way through
we talked about uh certifying Matrix
frame yeah
you said you can do this using toward
your hands like crazy yeah
okay and later uh yeah
and so so then later then you talked
about uh later you um I had an
interactive protocol for it yes yeah but
then later you went with the sparse
friends
yeah and I cannot do this
there
like you have uh the rank of a spark
Matrix you had the the Hopeless Matrix
the conditioning that was yeah well I
should let you ask you a question is
this is preconditioning why does that
not work for the dense case
or or does it like if you presented two
schemes which will puts one's being
simpler to me
special
thank you
yeah this may work yeah okay
yeah actually yeah
but but uh but you see uh
uh for the rank for this pass rank
we have interactivity
so it works it's quadratic it's like
honest or Johan's rank
but it makes that Assumption of a random
public random function sure
so so this is this is true but but you
know then you don't for first pass yeah
it's it's a good remark
excellent observation because it didn't
occur to me